your son of doing so my mercy father if
I speak Italian should we try this
peacefully in Warsaw Ghetto preferito
fee Nora in aura is up to now because
they also are your favorite your
favorite dish so so you also you ask
that you know when you when you when you
want to when you go when we have
somebody for example you go to a
restaurant and you've never been in bed
with somebody that has been there is you
ask them for they will cap toe preferito
in this restaurant quad
we're there wow wow wow hey can you say
and and they say it's tricky with the
apostrophe you always have to kind of
give it that little quiet companion yeah
hello yeah you want to
you're right
Troy quality of preparing for battle it
out in toco metacam dog yonder in
italiano italian also choco choco choco
you're sort of you in it so catch it
catch it like 70 parlando de platicar
affinity but I Tokyo finito finito if
people paititi to keynote for bait and
Walter investigated it Zara la pizza
quite savvy ducato casa será su la pizza
marteria for a job are you and I will
Pomodoro like the golden the Golden Pond
commander
Valentina benissimo en tu crois que esta
será esta será facciamo in dolce casa
grande zenefits amo ill tiramisu
tiramisu what a serious women so today
is either is either used you see Tina
lock on this is actually to pull the
rope this is like tra and but it's also
associated re-up and it's also it's also
okay so-so tigra me is throw me and Sue
is up okay okay so it's you if you if
you do a permutation here that field if
you tell me where we move all these
things around you could actually have a
throw-up issue it's much nicer than a
pig so we'll do mallu tiramisu will go I
guess I guess we go through the
ingredients when we are
over there and there's an important
component that actually is is it's
relevant it gets culturally for an
Italian which is that we need coffee so
we're gonna we're going to do is priced
own whoo we're gonna make that okay all
right so so but but the the price is
important so so how long how many of you
are you guys no no no what up with the
perfect espresso mousse right so if you
can fan and I cause any more important
issues of it off via video when you win
go earlier when you're going on when
you're going on here when you wake up in
the morning you go to bar yes when you
don't ask first place so you don't ask
you did you just you just go home café
in espresso well well instantaneously
appear in front so so you go in and you
say and you say what oil in the cafe and
the bartender will say I'm Kiwis on your
bazooka Fraser also good work it would
make you extremely loved by I want
coffee yeah so does the word come on
Daria meeting can you take pokemon
pokemon data so it so it's very very old
Italian I mean like amanda was that was
a very very old term to say defense for
a waiter to take an order yeah it is it
rude
c'mon daddy is more is more referred to
to when to giving orders actually so you
take it with more so it was more like
that you know like a captain will know
it will come on da a Newfie Charlie okay
you know like like the calendar yeah but
but so so you want to say when you when
you when you go with you when you go in
a bar you say generally it's very it's
very short and just say honk effect
perform one and then it will appear
magically otherwise you say for today or
pasta or possibly a course also I guess
can I it's a verb the infinite form of
the verb is both a la which also which
also means power equal take before there
but but also is is is the first form of
the present and so it means camera and
so also it also can i have and then have
is heavy right pasta
ties are pretty picky they have about 15
varieties once a once they have the
espresso they have either the one that
the one that has a little bit of
chocolate the one that has an extra foam
there's macchiato condom makita friendo
makiato caldo macchiato yeah so but yea
though someone catcher comes from comes
from machi Omar Kearse pot so so you
know if you're out of here if you're
eating a burger something falls and
you're sure there's a man yet for your
too much chalk on my sweater so so much
giotto maquette oh is it with a little
bit of a little bit of milk my cattle
cattle meketa fried dough is whether you
get all I want so so these are in this
is all affect con la effect or not to do
it so it's so it's a little bit it's a
lot different than the you mean like
like like the lattes that you get here
so so that's so that's actually kind of
an old know thing that you get the
ticket as a kid as educators is a big
breakfast drink is called the cafe latte
and and it's and it's what what you call
a lot is it with you I felt like the
court dalaman spain and like they're not
was it France like it's like it at least
press it with a tiny little bit of foam
yeah there's a there's like a drop looks
like a drop a drop of phone at the top
and then if you put if you put some
cocoa powder on top is called in my
Tokyo maracas and if you put graphite is
called colorectal you come in a fake or
rectal cafe co-writer something you get
at the end of the at the end of the meal
and you had a shot of a shot of grappa
to it get up bum what is that face
basically turpentine you can't you can't
put that yes I can excellent it's a it's
it's a very strong it's very strong
distilled liquor it's a blanket and very
short shots country rock around yourself
so my tattoo is one thing but probably
those popular then correlate it was
actually very very upper to sopo tonight
yeah
all your are as well so that's so that's
that's gathered that that means
literally corrected so it's like going
like when you when you wait your exams
having this like checkmark multi it's
that time of year generally to actually
make a good a good espresso you have the
four ends did you hear about this for
Horace priceville so a good especially
has four to make a good especially need
you need for him what is what is the the
matching up the move on Sheena Sheena
like too much right second one is as
this we [ __ ] let me shade I'm very good
very good mattoon de back here my
feeling my money a monkey imagine a
monkey it says remember that the CH is
that eh as always is always close that
calf in Italian eyes it's like them it's
like them looks like a cool skate not
the bruschetta so mocking up and then so
so Matt worries what'swhat's matching a
machine no I'm like oh that's marvelous
a mechanism machine right so my spatula
so macchina is what do you do when you
have the beans right here and right so
to grind the beans is much in attic oh
so it's how how finally the coffee is
ground you have to the coffee has to be
ground apparently apparently
and then we shade out with lets me
Shayla so so it means mixture and so
mixture mixture is the is the blends of
coffee and how the coffee is roasted and
what click click on our hands and then
mono mono is minus the hand of the
person that makes the coffee so you can
have all these things work and those
coffee makers are actually are actually
are some kind of kind of household
staples they became all designer II now
and you can find them at all in all
different different shapes and sizes but
that they're kind of iconic these are I
think that these are power because they
likely to have that little strange
strange guy with a mustache of it goes
as a brand okay
and sometimes sometimes you actually use
the brand of the reality is there is a
manufacturer that there's no reason
really to who knows it's except that
maybe sometimes when you go in a store
you say I'd like valio or Lang comprare
or posso comprare una y la tee and they
know that you're looking for and the
other way to call to call that
colocalize oka lemak among Democrats and
it smelled mm okay very few uses of cake
so we'll have to we'll have to do that
we'll have to split I think that once
once we well it's a small group I think
it in there tonight so it's probably 11
group but we have to kind of divide and
conquer get to make a bunch of coffee on
the one hand and then there's the
whiskey part and it's going to be good
at whisking because I and then in the
Mogul will go through the recipe and
maybe we'll go through the recipe over
there and we'll go through what most
were the ingredients and kept along with
a little with some panic goes away so
should we start cooking see ya yeah Tara
yeah I'm going to put you down
by travelpod member